thinking the wrong line compadre nope
doesn't seem like your dress for strong
for squad actually I am bucko
there is no parrot and strong for squad
yeah there is the parrot is always just
off-screen so you can't see it what how
can you tell there is no way there is no
way all the screaming and the explosions
that happen in that scene were is that
fun and power clock fight the Infinia
sink in New York City that would scare a
parrot sure they got a professional
parrot who's been trained to be break Oh
so the parrot would have squawk during
tank no I don't know what to tell you
read the original comic books ok zap
pawn and dr. struggle they have a whole
conversation in the strong force HQ
about how there's always a parrot just
out of frame
nice cosplayer the parent that's always
just off-screen thank you Desmond you
too you're coming in a little hot have a
Snickers guess it is possible there
could be a parrot that's slightly
off-screen good cosplay man there you go
also never disagree with the celebrity
again it's very rude because you're that
superhero fan when you're hungry eat a
Snickers